I know this is Dr. Conner's again, and I'm answering some important questions that a lot of people have
Here's a common one is hyperthermia the same as sauna a lot of people say hypothermia
It's hyperthermia
Increase in temperature is that the same as using a sauna. Well, let's talk about that
It's hyperthermia the same as a sauna
Well, this is the hyperthermia unit that we use. It's called localized hyperthermia the picture on your left here
The localized hyperthermia is true
far infrared so you won't see a light you won't see
You know any any lights like you do in the the infrared
sauna
Units that you use because it is a true infrared. That's why it's much more expensive. We get this and source this on Japan
They use this actually. I was told that they use this in over 600 hospitals in Japan for cancer and all sorts of different things
There is a full-body hyperthermia units available
They're not available in the United States that I know of they're used a lot in the German cancer clinics
You need to be sedated to go into those and you're in those for a number of hours. I think the I heard it each between
Three and seven hours you have to be sedated because it's so hot the purpose of that is it's producing a fever like state
So they're raising the full-body hyperthermia units are raising your body temperature up to a hundred and four hundred and five degrees
That's your core body temperature in order to kill the cancer the idea is that cancer cells are much less stable
Then your normal healthy cells. So if you increase the temperature of the cancers the cancer itself
You're going to cause it to become more
Unstable and you can cause it to
Lice you could cause cell lysis through doing hyperthermia by increasing the temperature
Well, how do we increase the temperature of the cancer?
Well, one of the ways is with a hyperthermia unit
So a hyperthermia unit a localized one is where you could do it right over the skin
It has to be a skin contact. You can't do this through a shirt
So you have to be bare skinned and you put it about six inches away from the skin and you turn it on
Typically for about 40 minutes per session and you run it now
It will feel warm. It will feel comfortable, but you won't feel burning and you won't feel like oh my gosh
I'm so hot or anything like that. That's what a hyperthermia unit does
Asana is completely different. Asana is where you're going in there to sweat
These are the units that we like right here. This is where you have your head out of or there's the wooden ones that you can get into and
The whole body saw us. They're totally different and have a totally different purpose. So let's talk about these
The positives of hyperthermia. Well, the positives are it's deep heat to underlying tissue
It's going to be only deep heat to where you have that unit
It's very good for breast. It's very good for liver at least the lower lobe of the liver
It can be good for the pancreas that can be good for skin cancers
So it's going to be deep heat to the tissue that you have that under the idea again is that you're disrupting cancer cells because cancer cells are not going to be
As stable at high temperature. So you're actually causing disruption and more instability of the cancer cells
These units are very helpful with pain and other symptoms as well
Matter of fact, we used to have people come to the clinic and they did this that they were the one pain
Many people not everybody, but it could help just like take the pain away miraculously
Because it does increase circulation to the area. It can heal
Nerve endings. It can heal other things by that as well. So there's other benefits to the hyperthermia
One of the creators of the hyperthermia a doctor who is from Japan who's actually doing work at John Hopkins right now
I spoke to her just a few weeks ago and she said that she's seen the greatest benefit because she does she's not a practitioner
but she
Loves these units. She's one of the developers of this these units
She's loaned about to people with chronic pain. So people with chronic pain syndrome
This has really been helped with so that can be a positive to the negatives are the depth is limited
So this isn't going to go four inches deep through your ribcage to your lungs
But it's not going to go through your ribs to your upper lobes of your liver either
And it's not going to get through you know three inches of tissue to get to your prostate gland
It's just not going to go that deep. So that is the issue with it now. There's medical studies on hyperthermia
I saw a video
a few years back of the Cleveland clinic using hyperthermia to kill breast cancer cells
And that's where it really shines in most use is with breast cancer
They were using hyperthermia to kill breast cancer cells
But they weren't using far and far and far and they're using microwave
Now the danger of that is
How do you dose that because you do you turn it up? You have it on too long
You're basically microwaving your you're cooking your flesh
So just like if you couldn't possibly put your hand in the microwave you would literally cook your hand
So very dangerous
And really is touchy to know how you know how much you are using the dose that you're using
With the fire and for red this one this hyperthermia you cannot do harm unless you did it right over your eyes or something like that
So you can't hurt yourself
You can't you know cook yourself you can't damage tissue
That's the beauty of this unit. There's no way that you can damage tissue with it
But if the tumors too deep it's not going to get there. So it has pros and cons
Plus you have to understand that there's nothing perfect
So even if I have a very superficial tumor by doing this doesn't mean that it's going to kill the cancer cells
So but it's just another tool to consider and we do have these available on our store for that reason
Now as opposed to a sauna
A sauna has totally different purposes the positives of a sauna is to heat
And induce detoxification so your your organs of detoxification are your liver and your kidneys and your colon and your skin
So anyway we can take pressure off of our kidneys and our colon and our liver is a good thing
So if we can use our skin to sweat out toxins is that's going to do nothing but help us get better
May it disrupt cancer cells as well by increasing heat sure could it's possible
I'm very big on sonas the nice thing about these little sonas is now we have this particular model that I think is $1200
It's just fantastic. It does fold up and can slide underneath your bed
But they're great little units and personally I like the ones where your head sticks out
That's just my personal favorite because otherwise I feel a little claustrophobic
I feel like I can't breathe in a closed in a full body sauna after a period of time
I'd like to be able to breathe that I don't want to be breathed in my toxins and my sweat either
So I think there's some benefits to having your head out
Now the negatives are the depth is very limited now
There's studies that show that these sonas could actually raise your core temperature
I don't know how much of that is little bit
You know hyperbole or not. Yes, it may raise it, you know, you know, several tenths of a
Of a point
I don't know that you're really getting up to 100 in water or anything like that of
These sonas but
Sonas are so good in so many ways you just cannot argue the benefits of a sauna so
Very big of the sonas. So what's what's better? Should I use the hyperthermia or should I use the sauna?
You can't say that they're totally different pieces of equipment doing different things
So just because I am a hyperthermia unit does not mean I wouldn't do a sauna
Advice a versus so they're very different pieces of equipment
To to solve different problems they can be both beneficial for your health
It's not one or the other now. There's cost involved like the the hyperthermia right now is I don't know
5500 bucks or something the sonas are $1200 so boy if the cost was an issue I'd get a sauna
So weigh that out and also depends on your cancer
I'm colon cancer don't get a hyperthermia get a sauna so if I am breast cancer it's fairly close to the surface
Well, then maybe hyperthermia is the way to go. So think about those things
And if you need to talk contact us we'll talk you through that and discuss your particular cancer your particular concern
And help you walk through that decision-making process
We're here for you for that reason
So there's no way to it anything for us to know this is the right thing for you
Are even when we do our testing we're just praying over it and asking the Holy Spirit to guide us and all things
And that's what you need to do too you need to be asking the Holy Spirit to guide you and what you should be doing
Maybe you're doing too much and you need to just relax and let God do this and you need to go live your life
Maybe you do need to add a piece of equipment or something like that too
That is for you to decide and that has to be done through prayer
We're here to pray with you know that and we're praying for you at all times. Thanks